ah they fooled me into watching another
pirates movie god dammit
it is said the blood thicker than water
it is said that every movie starts with
narration these days it is said the
blood thicker than water a factual
statement and also a cliche it is what
defines us binds us curses that might
apply to you specifically Barnabas but
for everyone else you're pretty much
over three amending in place poor
servant child wearing very nice clothes
made of seemingly expensive fabrics my
father took us to the new world use of
the term new world peaked in the mid
17th century when European explorers
were actively navigating the globe and
discovering new lands Barnabas meanwhile
I went to Maine which had its first
European settlers over 150 years earlier
in 1604 so saying the new world instead
of saying the colonies is some affected
old-fashioned bulls even for someone
reminiscing about 1760 you're not
Magellan also most Tim Burton films can
be found out of the Netflix category
affected old-fashioned bulls unnecessary
witchy hand gesturing
did Angelique cast a spell on mr. and
mrs. Collins that made them go on a walk
so she could drop a stone sea horse on
them or did she just lock the cow also
how the hell did she time this she's
definitely in some completely different
location there's no way she could know
when they would be in just the right
spot probably would have been easier for
her to just cast a spell on them or
hypnotized them to walk off a cliff like
she does with Barnabas his girlfriend
later also how does crumbling up a sea
horse translate to a sea horse sculpture
falling off the structure it's mounted
on she also killed the dog and Barnabas
doesn't go full John wick on this
witch's ass nor do we even discuss it
convinced my parents death was no
accident I became obsessed with dog
magic right because why would you spend
that energy trying to figure out who
murdered your parents like a normal
person
mention amethyst appellees has no
importance to the story besides
providing a setup for a passing
MacDonnell's joke that will happen later
also I'm not sure this is what
MacDonald's had in mind when they paid
for this product placement but I had
found
one true love and instead of
establishing any relationship between
these two we'll just have them quickly
kissed so the audience will have zero
empathy for this character discount had
a grant of all the servants I could have
spurned I got the which you say of all
the servants but she is literally the
only servant we've seen so far and to be
honest if she was the only servant here
I'd also have trouble not spurning her
Claudine Angelique spell I beloved
Josette wandered helplessly towards
widows Hill where many a despondent soul
had left to their death and no one ever
thought of putting up a fence what is
the deal with Tim Burton and
blond-haired blue-eyed innocent girls
wearing blue dresses it's a fetish at
this point right not running to save
your beloved from certain depth person
under a spell somehow has enough rain
power to stop what they're doing for a
short amount of time still not running
to catch her and now she's dead
after 20 seconds of way b-roll Barnabas
gets up to discover that Angelique has
turned him into a vampire I guess to pad
the run time
Angelique turn the townspeople against
me after turning you into a vampire she
really just had to tell them where you
work so no turning against required also
are you gonna tell me that this whole
story exists because Barnabas couldn't
fall in love with Ava fuckin Greene I
know who the real antagonist is here hmm
four passenger cars here then five here
then back to four again what the
expositional newspaper clipping that
she's still holding for some reason is
expositional VW bus filled with hippies
in the early 70's cliche huh pardon me
but I didn't get to participate in 70s
too much was it really filled with leif
Garrett looking assholes who asked dumb
empty questions like this constantly
because that is what every modern
depiction of the 70s would lead me to
believe hello I'm Victoria winters
congratulations here to see miss
daughter about the governance position
yeah unexpected they've been expecting
her yet when he answered the door he
clearly had no idea why she was there
also wouldn't they be expecting her
under her actual name since she didn't
make up the name Victoria winters until
she was on the train who's that oh
that's just the protagonist of the movie
whose portrait you picked to discuss
over all the other portraits hanging in
this mansion because it's important to
the plot I am forcing you to see this
portrait in the background so you'll
make the connection this is called
subtlety also this brings up another
question or she and part of us married
we don't know because the movie offers
no information about this character but
I ask because if they weren't married
then why would they have her portrait in
their great room now I'm starting to
think the Barnabas fell in love with his
cousin or something the Collinses are
weird about family pretty impressive
that Carolyn is listening to a song that
won't be released for another five years
you're a liar leave her be Julia this
family hired Julia to help their son but
all she does is drink and insult other
house staff yet they put up with her
like she's a member of the family was a
rejection cotton this is as good a time
as any to ask this family is so
poverty-stricken then how are they able
to maintain this house I heard the bit
earlier about closing off one of the
wings but it's still a giant-ass house
that property taxes alone are probably
more than they can afford selling the
house seems like a logical decision but
even these idiots would have made years
earlier yes y'all voting on the higher
and David's mothers at the bottom of
nineveh this isn't normal teenage
victory this is full-on emotional abuse
Carolyn needs to be in military school
ghosts Josette or perhaps Cosette was
wearing the sheet like David in the
previous scene because ghosts ed has a
sense of humor and decided this would be
hilarious misdirection also she
crabs also why would Josette have ghost
crabs growing around her are those the
crabs that died when she crashed into
the rock
are they duty-bound to make her creepier
you've got it
grab me some bolt cutters discount what
Harrelson would rather have bolt cutters
instead of calling this in to the
higher-ups so that they can investigate
the strange chained up coffin they found
in the ground I thought I was going on
with this guy
he gets hooked with a crowbar by the
neck then in the next shot he's getting
pulled up into the air by nothing I'm
terribly sorry
cannot imagine how so still if he really
was sorry then was this necessary
screenwriter shirt thought so because
that moment paved the way for this
that's a stop which is great because we
were all able to not get a laugh at that
joke also the cuz I'm ik Donald's doing
way out here in the middle of King woods
Barnabas is able to walk through town
with blood all over him and no one
notices I might forgive this if he was
walking through New York City in the
1970s but in rural Maine people would
get suspicious the Collins family do
they endure yeah
oh wait a minute did Barnabas his
parents have any other children maybe
they did but all we saw on the first
scene was the young Barnabas and his two
parents this movie could have least
shown a weird cousin or a brother or
something because right now it seems
like the Collins bloodline should end at
Barnabas are you stoned or something
they tried stoning me my dear he did not
work
uh-huh hilarious misunderstanding but
didn't the townspeople just grab him and
bury him alive most of the jokes are
derived from simply showing the audience
things from the 70s and Barnabus
grimacing at it what is known of his
death nothing not that I can think of
surely the collinsport townspeople would
have made up a story to justify killing
Barnabas and wrote it down somewhere
nice of the family to position their
cereal boxes dead center on the dining
table for maximum viewing pleasure my
god a woman doctor
what an age this is that's racist I see
that you have grown desperate enough to
callosity prized family he's Lulu how
could you tell these were exact replicas
if they were truly hurting for money why
did they go out of their way to pay
someone to make exact replicas other
other silverware had this folk been real
silver manhandled and burst into flames
on its slightest touch then why was he
even trying to touch it in the first
place
if it's an exact replica he'd have no
reason to suspect his hand would do
anything but that upon touching the fork
then you
I found eleven workers dead in the woods
off route 9 this morning we're supposed
to believe that Angelique somehow didn't
get this news until this very moment
very cool of the cops to let the rich
lady mill about the horrific crime scene
didn't you go home and change clothes
but it's definitely not what she was
wearing the last scene what was the wig
budget for this movie a hundred dollars
we're growing into quite the section
creature Angelique
Jesus does Michelle Pfeiffer live at the
top of these stairs she's never anywhere
else when she makes an entrance he's
asleep I'm afraid during the day haha
don't be ridiculous auntie naps existed
in the 70s just ask my dad how dare you
defile my mana with your noxious I'm
telling you guys this movie would end
here for me
like this would happen and the next shot
is some sort of Addams Family style
wedding and kicks the spider a character
I would have introduced somewhere in the
second act and you'd have no context for
would be playing that violin he was
searching forward through all that part
that got cut out it's a work in progress
based on this movie and cuts out
significant details but the point is if
Ava green kisses me the movies over
that's all
the only big fish left Nellie
so in 200 years a powerful witch managed
to take over a small fishing village be
more ambitious even though the Collinses
are wealthy again after discovering the
basement full of goodies barnabas still
doesn't have enough money to acquire a
nice coffin to sleep it Barnabas is
using a mirror even though he has no
reflection also or his clothes the
vampire why are we just seeing a
floating toothbrush and not a floating
toothbrush and a floating row this song
was released in 1972 but became a hit in
1973 and this performance was taped in
1973 so unless they have time-traveling
television there's no way they could be
watching this new yourself
tiny songs Barnabas pulls the back of
this television off and it still kind of
works movie will try to have us believe
that even though he is sensitive to
sunlight he can get away with not
covering his face at all Christopher Lee
is only in this movie for 30 seconds
madam I do not believe that remotely
blows not only is Julia able to
hypnotize Barnabas at all she is able to
hypnotize him this quickly 15 and no
husband absolute both the average age
women married even in Barnabas's time
was in their late teens to early 20s 15
year olds getting married pretty much
only happened in royal or aristocratic
families so those are the ones people
learn about and mistakenly think were
common she has the most fertile versing
hips I have
Spa I don't want to research if that is
an okay thing for an 18th century person
to say it just feels weird I am a picker
I madrina I am know this song doesn't
come out until a year from now Jesus did
anyone research any of these songs
before tossing them into the movie can't
wait for Barnabas to sing that early 70s
hit karma chameleon these hippies still
exist this girl doesn't get to have any
pop for some reason the doc had a dose
of one so roll credits sing love thanks
Gilley from Game of Thrones when they
were making this film Tim Burton and
Seth grahame-smith unequivocally agreed
that the original Dark Shadows series
was great but lacked blowjobs this is
their attempt to write that wrong
actually I came down looking for David
God knows where he's run off to now so
the depressed kid whose mother drowned
hangs around by the rocks and violent
waves good to know that no one seems to
give a shit you do still leave me don't
you Angie didn't hear him 200 years ago
when he said he didn't love her the
first time honestly there's very little
sex happening here it's mostly just
destroying her office here's a demon
tongue because witches have demon
tongues now Victoria is dreaming about
some backstory I'm not sure what's
scarier coset or the baby doll Vickie is
playing with Vickie's parents are
concerned about their adolescent
daughter having an imaginary friend
medical professionals take and medicate
a little girl for as far as they know
having an imaginary friend help me help
you what
I'm glad this moment was here because
now we know nothing the Collins family
have always held the biggest most
wonderful balls
oh yes America loves a good testicle
joke Alice Cooper it worked out that she
was reading a Rolling Stone issue from
the end of March and not the one from
the end of August if he was Randy Newman
might have been the headliner having the
guy who played the lead character in the
original version of the story show up in
an unrecognizable cameo cliche
and they not only got Alice Cooper to
come here but he sounds exactly like he
does on the record sweet also an Alice
Cooper looks old like as old as he looks
now and this is 1972
Barnabas hypnotizes David so that he'll
leave and he can bust Roger for being a
thief but the next time we see him he's
hanging outside the window something he
could have done without hypnotizing this
kid and telling him to leave also gotta
say this whole sequence is confusing
Roger is Elizabeth's brother but this
plays out like Barnabas is busting Roger
for cheating on his wife or something
but Roger's wife you may remember drown
then immediately after this happens
mommy where's daddy
he's been gone for so long
is he ever coming here admittedly I
totally forgot they were brother and
sister but that's because this movie
sucks he was a kid no idea I never saw
him before dad moves beyond neglectful
ingredient a total asshole territory
over an hour into the film with this
movie have lost anything by cutting this
character entirely there's no point to
him grabbing a microphone and it feeding
back for no reason I wonder what that
guitar player is using to give his
electric guitar that pure acoustic
guitar sound no why
some reason I feel like I can tell you
anything question has victorious evening
obviously her painting hanging in the
house yet has that freaked her out at
all
or how about how she grew up to look
like that ghost she got thrown into the
asylum for talking to swept me under the
rug because it was easier than having a
daughter who was different this is in
every fucking Tim Burton movie every one
of them you're not using your blood to
make me human you're using my blood to
make yourself mortal any wonder why this
movie sucks and didn't connect with
audiences there are a lot of disjointed
plot points concerning characters we
don't give a shit about it tried to be a
full season of soap opera in two hours
julia was using Barnabas as blood to
make herself immortal so when she drains
her body and subsequently this bag of
blood he's drinking a lot of his own
blood right Matt probably tastes weird
Barnabas where's his son protective
Michael Jackson outfit in the middle of
the night
just in case the Sun decides to rise
early Barnabas and the other guy don't
cover Julia's face presumably because
her eyes will dramatically open later
and we need to be able to see it this
there's nothing with stealing I'm afraid
yet another secret door but who built a
secret room for something this fucking
small anyway I might feel bad about this
father leaves his kid seen if the movie
devoted even five minutes to their
characters
clumsy sadness Barnabus stand in the
sunlight and doesn't move even though
he's on fire
that is a dry ass bucket considering he
just used it to dump water on part of us
I demand that you release me from my
class you're late because as we've
learned over the years whenever there's
a meeting someone's late like that
matter Barnabus doesn't use his super
speed to escape the situation before
he's in Chains sleeping flame I summoned
me just like the Harry Potter witches
and wizards Angelique sometimes has to
intone a spell but other times she can
just make things happen with a hand
gesture so I'm still confused with the
ways of witches it's all purple-ish
explosions because this is a Tim Burton
film nothing can be the color it
actually is centuries before Angie had
him buried in the ground and he got out
in about 200 years but now to make sure
he really stays she's just going to set
him inside a mausoleum where he can be
easily found ah Christ Angie ain't got
time for chitchat the damn town's
burning it's one thing building it would
seem that all the townspeople are also
vampires with superhuman speed because
they were able to arrive at Collinwood
only seconds after the police did you've
been harboring a murderer she's not
wrong I mean really all she's done in
the past 200 years is make the town
prosperous and marginalize a family of
total assholes she's no more villainous
than the entire Collins family movie
gives us no explanation for why after
all these years and she starts literally
cracking the only reason I can come up
with is there are only 15 minutes left
in the movie and we need to wrap this up
since the movie is just randomly giving
Angie all the evil powers they can come
up with they might as well throw in the
vomiting from The Exorcist
thanks a leak even though she was
clearly outside just before this
Elizabeth makes yet another entrance at
the top of the staircase just so you
know things that were never alive in the
first place just came to life but can be
killed by bullets
I'm werewolf okay let's not make a big
deal of it entirely sure this isn't just
puberty or something she's still mostly
the same as she was before also
something that might have been
interesting for this movie is thrown
away as a joke pretty much killing the
whole reason for making this revelation
a surprise
you're perfect Collins pedigree lacked a
bit of substance so I sent the werewolf
abit Carolyn in her crib wait a
fifteen-minute you mean she's been a
werewolf since she was a baby how the
fuck did Elizabeth not know her own
daughter was a werewolf all those years
she would have turned several times
before she could be old enough to hide
it right instead of having David's mom
actually do something to defeat Angie
movie just has her screen because that's
something moms do also gotta admit
David's ghost mom is freaky
somehow kills the previously
indestructible Angie because ghosts
power
chandelier physics 200 years later and
still no one's put up a fence Oh grow
old and die you'll live forever you can
find a way my love I know the way you
know the way just turn her into a
vampire already so I can go to bed says
that so did Joseph
jump into her body was she joe said all
along does she just want to be called
joe said what was the point of Josette's
ghost telling Vicki to help her again
the fuck
being a vampire would be tough but if
you have a vampire spouse you would get
the best back scratches it is said no
one gives a Jew lays eyes will open in
three two
also sequel oh wait
this is the one this is the one I'll be
remembered for
where were you born Liverpool can you
describe it for me it's a hole in the
world like a great black pit in the
vermin of the world inhabit it and it's
morals aren't worth what a pig could
spit and it goes by the name of
Liverpool that sounds about it's about
aliens with the aliens man and savages
we're not worthy we're not worthy I want
you to tell all your friends about me
what are you I'm Batman
only if you could promise me you'll
never die you know I can't promise that
if you did that I would make love to you
right now I promise I will never die
she's a black river perhaps it is not
too deep too
you